hi Ben this is Robert Forbes from Forbes
media and children's author love your
question about how to engage youth one
of the things I think is happening we're
not having an awful lot about here but
is changing the way the world works a
social media some people think it's
irrelevant it's a passing fad it is
changing the way we all interact
trade-ideas get our news find out what
our friends are doing I think the
long-term effects both the healthcare
education bringing the world closer
together it's going to be phenomenal and
I look forward to hearing what the other
youth and those who are not so young
anymore have to say about that in any
case we're looking forward to a good
year ahead thanks